it is 609 on your monday morning there
were more than 150
crash fatalities last year in metro's
jurisdiction you might be wondering are
there some roads you should avoid
well there is a list of intersections
with the most crashes in 2021 saharan
decatur charleston and lamb flamingo
maryland parkway flamingo las vegas
boulevard nellis and stewart both metro
and aaron breen the director of unity's
road equity alliance project say there's
a lot more to it
now all this week we're going to be
showing you five of the most dangerous
intersections in town that includes
right here on the valley's near west
side at charleston and rainbow
while some of the most dangerous
intersections include mostly just car
crashes this one has seen a combination
of fatal and serious injury car
pedestrian crashes aaron breen what you
have is two 45 mile an hour streets
wide intersection
high speed you know on any given morning
the average speed on that street is
way north of 55.
so
there are specific intersections that
could be considered more dangerous than
others but if you have drivers or
pedestrians not following the rules not
paying attention or both a dangerous
intersection
can be anywhere
now tomorrow we'll take you to an
intersection that's been on most traffic
watchers bad list for a long time and
still is you could probably guess what
that is we'll for sure tell you about it
tomorrow but there are many
intersections around town that people
just go oh no you want to stay away from
that one
well and for different reasons i can
imagine because i can think of some in
my head sure yes well we have a red
light running problem a speeding problem
a talking
problem and i think the bottom line from
all of this and we're going to be
repeating it all week but i think it's
worth repeating any intersection can be
dangerous if people aren't doing the
right thing